o
é o lá é marco gomes muito obrigado ao
pessoal do nbb pela oportunidade
é eu fui aluno da unb na computação
licenciatura durante três anos mas eu
fui expulso duas vezes e agora antes de
falar um pouco sobre essa história e
como como é contrariando as estatísticas
a gente vai como minha história é falar
um pouco sobre o trabalho estático na
verdade a gente vai falar sobre este
cara william choque
william choque era um engenheiro nos
anos 40 50 e ele ganhou um prêmio nobel
ele ganhou o prêmio nobel por conta
deste diagrama que esse diagrama o
diagrama se alguém for da mecatrônica e
com certeza vai conhecer é o diagrama a
do trânsito ele inventou o trânsito o
trânsito um dispositivo um componente
essencial para todos eletrônicos todos
os smartphones são apontados aqui pra
mim
nasceram dessa tecnologia é ele ganhou
um prêmio nobel e ganhando um prêmio
nobel ele ganhou renome e ganhou um
prêmio em dinheiro e ele fundou uma
empresa
achoque semicondutor laboratoriais em
mountain view califórnia escolheu ontem
view na califórnia
pra para fundar a empresa dele só que
ele era um péssimo gestor
ele criou uma empresa que ninguém queria
trabalhar
ele criou uma empresa que não dava
resultados ele criou uma empresa que tem
um ambiente muito ruim a uma das
estratégias dele que não foi
necessariamente uma estratégia é ruim
ele chamou os melhores pagadores jovens
da época trabalhar com ele e ver se ele
chama a gente como ele na casa dos 40 50
anos ele chamou as pegadas na casa dos
20 e 30 é de altíssimo potencial mas
ainda sem nome que ele conseguiria
atrair essas pessoas melhor mas mesmo
assim essas pessoas queriam elas são
ambições elas queriam coisas que a
choques em conduta laboratórios não dava
e esses caras saíram do shopping quando
o laboratório e fundaram a fértil de
semicondutores afetadas semicondutores
oito desses caras saíram da choque
semicondutor laboratórios fundaram a
fértil de semicondutores e por terem
saído eles são chamados de os oito
traidores
depois a gente vai falar mais um pouco
sobre esses caras mas a mantém isso aqui
na memória os 8
28 traidores eles é fundar um fértil de
semicondutores na fértil foi inventado
também um microprocessador o microchip é
o placa de circuito integrado que ela
aquela placa verde com os tracinhos cor
de cobre que a gente vê nos eletrônicos
e tal
tudo isso foi inventado aqui na frente
ao já foi chamada de a mãe de todas as
etapas porque porque foi a fé chardy que
criou o que a gente conhece como vale do
silício a região entre são francisco e
são josé nos estados unidos o coração a
limpá-lo alto onde nasci tudo o que a
gente entende sobre tecnologia e
internet o basicamente tudo quase tudo
que a gente conhece como tecnologia
internet é nasce aí nessa região a
montagem vil é aí também então a decisão
lá do william choque de fazer a empresa
nesse lugar mudou não só a economia ea
ea estrutura deste lugar como também
definiu que a gente conhece como
tecnologia existem 90 e tantas empresas
cuja origem se dá na fértil de
semicondutores essas são algumas das
empresas que têm a sua origem
lá na fértil e com pessoas que estavam
na fértil ou que pessoas que estavam na
fechada influenciaram nascimento dessas
empresas só pra falar algumas é pouco
gol ora com o facebook intel cisco ibm
yahoo amazon tesla é twitter linkedin
entre tantas outras
aqueles oito caras eles criaram 2.1
trilhões de dólares na economia
americana não eles com o trabalho deles
apenas claro mas a decisão deles de sair
fundara fechado semicondutores fifa
criar e aquele ambiente que a gente
chama de vale do silício gerou 2.1
trilhão de 2.1 trilhões de dólares na
economia americana
e aí beleza vamos pular aí
quarenta anos depois mais ou menos 2001
distrito federal que é o ambiente onde
eu me encontrava assim e 86 em 2008
tinha 15 anos e 16 anos e estava
estudando a eu estava no ensino médio e
eu podia falar aqui sobre como é difícil
no gama e como o tráfico de drogas
atrapalhava ea não tinha dinheiro e isso
e aquilo mas a ideia que não é fazer
vitimismo é então vamos pular um pouco
essa parte falar um pouco do geral é no
geral o dólar antes de falar
o papa cadê o áudio dos jovens de
periferia sem antecedentes criminais já
sofreram violência policial a cada
quatro pessoas mortas pela polícia três
são negras brasileiras apenas 2% dos
alunos são negros
a cada quatro horas mais um sobrevivente
então pra não fazer vitimismo falar de
tarde estatística que é a proposta que
dalton a quem aqui sei lá cresceu na
ceilândia
vamos ver se tem alguém ceilândia tem
alguns samambaia é alguém é recanto das
emas são sebastião é esses lugares de
periferia quando a gente está inserido
a gente não percebe porque tem asfalto
tem água encanada tem esgoto eu vou na
escola e às vezes longe de casa às vezes
perto beleza
só que a gente coloca em perspectiva
principalmente perspectiva no mundo
globalizado onde existe o vale do
silício
você não percebe que você está numa
desvantagem absurdo em relação a essas
pessoas
por exemplo a taxa de homicídios de
jovens e eu saí levantando dados aí
fiquei dias levantando dados para poder
trazer dados interessantes aqui pra
palestra taxa de homicídios de
adolescentes a cada 100 mil habitantes é
seis vezes maior aqui do que nos estados
unidos
mesmo que você morre do coração da zona
norte e da zona sul do lago
a taxa de homicídio no distrito federal
é muito muito mais alta então mais do
que fazer vitimismo falar ao tráfico de
drogas e isso e aquilo é perceber que
quando você coloca as coisas em
perspectiva
você já sai de uma desvantagem muito
grande mas que isso lá em 2001 quando
estava crescendo só 4,3 por cento dos
adolescentes
trabalhava e desses 4,3 por cento que
trabalhavam
você tinha um texto de chance de ter um
sub emprego de está trabalhando como
empregada doméstica empregada doméstica
então só 48 3% trabalhavam desses 43 por
3 0 que trabalhava um em cada três
estávamos numa situação de subemprego de
exploração trabalhar significava quase
que necessariamente os 72% 73 por cento
de chance de você está em situação de
desvantagem escolar trabalhar a gente o
governo e todo mundo tentava falar não
atrapalha não é possível fazer sem
atrapalhar é realmente possível se fazer
sem atrapalhar mas taticamente falando
não é verdade
o botão adolescente para trabalhar do
jeito que a gente botava em 2001
é naquela situação era 73 por cento de
chance de ele enfrentar defasagem
escolar só 27% estavam em situação é
regular na escola acesso à internet era
uma exceção só 10,3 por cento tinha
acesso à internet em casa e aqui era o o
oac essa exceção que estava de 10,3 por
cento com acesso à internet em casa é
mas não também de maneira fácil eu tive
eu meus tios eles eram bombeiros eles é
um paraguai trazendo peças de computador
montar uma espécie de computador e vende
em brasília não estavam com as peças e
montavam computadores e vendiam os
computadores em brasília ainda no jornal
etc
mas eles me deram a um monte de peça
velha com esse monte de peça velha é
muito velha mesmo computador 98 não
tinha nem mouse era tela a preto e
branco nessa época
caso vocês não têm esse contexto
histórico já tinha jogo em 3d já
tínhamos internet já tínhamos muita
coisa legal eu não tenho contou com
peças realmente muito muito velhas
sucatas em mauriti e tal
os estudantes do ensino superior os dez
jovens dos 10% mais ricos tinha 130 por
cento mais chances de ser estudante de
ensino superior do que o jovem dos 30
por cento mais pobres
então se você fala de a meritocracia
quem se esforça consegue se esforça e
consegue te ter muito cuidado com essa
afirmação que só se consegue rock mas se
você é pobre
você está numa situação muito muito
mais difícil do que um jovem rico dos
10% mais ricos detêm se você for rico
você tem 130 por cento mais chances de
entrar numa escola de ensino superior
em 2001 era assim e a gente não tinha
empregadores não tinha empreendedores na
sociedade só 4,5 por cento do aço da da
população econômica ativa economicamente
ativa do df era empreendedor era criar
criava emprego estava em situação de
empregador 95,5 por cento eram
empregadores
então o que a gente tinha a gente tinha
uma alta taxa de mortalidade por
homicídio a gente um alto desemprego
entre os ocupados muito sub-emprego alto
índice de defasagem escolar acesso à
internet era uma exceção dificuldade de
acesso ao ensino superior
empreendedorismo quase inexistente na
sociedade não tinha exemplo então de a
frase do haxixe que o rapper que eu
gosto muito ele fala que faz a gente
refletir bastante com as ferramentas que
entregaram tudo o que eu podia fazer era
nada
primeiro eram sonhos depois ela observa
da cidade vídeo comunidade segundo nos
deram a responsabilidade de ser o que
eles não tenha tal da honestidade sua má
imagem ensinar
a pc agora escreva botafogo
atuais na sua alma seis anos depois a
gente pula de novo flash forte para
2006/2007 já tinha 20 anos para 21 e eu
trabalhava numa grande agência de
publicidade eu tinha conseguido cruzar
até voltar eu tinha conseguido cruzar o
são paulo a gente agora mora em são
paulo a gente chama de cruzar o rio é
que quem mora além do rio na periferia e
quem mora no centro está entre rios
estão aqui eu tinha conseguido me mudar
eu estudava na unb tinha passado na
computação é morava ali na na zona norte
morava sozinho e tinha um carro só comia
comida crua e orgânica e integral eu era
tuper assim a qualidade de vida é muito
alta é eu tinha conseguir realmente sair
mas chegaram humana uma situação social
que eu não imaginava no gama jamais
imaginava que ia conseguir tinha
conseguido romper esses 44 quilômetros
que separam programa do dia de brasília
do plano piloto
eu estava numa situação muito
confortável trabalhando na agência de
publicidade é passar num concurso
público pra pra funcionário público
federal no cérebro e depois vão ver que
eu resolvi não assumir mas eu ia poderia
ser funcionário público federal hoje se
eu quisesse então estava numa situação
realmente eu tinha pra aquele
adolescente que a gente viu lá de 2000
de 13 e 14 anos de idade tinha vencido
na vida e eu trabalhava numa agência de
publicidade eu fiz a seguinte pergunta
e se a gente fizer publicidade de
alta qualidade em blogs que na época
tinha toda uma situação econômica que
toda publicidade na internet era
veiculada em portais e os blogs são
muito audiência ninguém estava
explorando essa essa oportunidade de
negócio e tal
publiquei eu fiz um protótipo de
publicidade alta qualidade em blogs
publiquei essa esse protótipo saiu o
atacante que é uma sorte
empreendedorismo tecnologia do mundo é
isso me gerou isso me gerou uma
oportunidade de criar uma empresa de me
mudar para são paulo para fazer uma
empresa em são paulo de publicidade de
tecnologia com investimento de empresas
e investidores e tal mas são paulo de
novo estatísticas a situação era a
seguinte 27 por cento das empresas
morria no primeiro ano um terço das
empresas morrem no primeiro ano e 62%
morria antes do quinto ano então se você
abrir uma empresa porto
atualmente há aparentemente você vai
morrer você tem que lutar para estar
aqui nessa nessa área das estatísticas
né
mais que isso os empreendedores não eram
nem um pouco parecido comigo só a 12%
deles tinha até 24 anos a o empreendedor
e não normalmente era bem mais velho
tinha faixa etária em média de 37 anos e
mais que isso ele sempre tinha recursos
próprios onde tinha feito uma grana ao
longo da vida e resolveu virar
empreendedor ou a família dele bancou
ele mais de 85% das da situação era essa
a gente tinha menos de 4% de pessoas
abrindo empresa com dinheiro de
investidor com dinheiro de investidor de
capital de risco muito menos de 4%
a gente tinha a seguinte situação um
terço das empresas fechavam no primeiro
ano a maioria fechada antes do quinto
ano de operação os empresários
experientes em média eram em média 17
anos mais velhos que eu e a eles tinham
dinheiro próprio ou de família os
investimentos eram praticamente
inexistentes e mesmo assim resolvi a
mudar para são paulo que a gente tem o
início do nosso escritório lá
aqui a gente tem uma primeira reunião
que a gente fez a com um cara dos
investidores aqui vocês vão ver que
então de camisa e tal
e esse menino aqui de dread locks e
regata pergunta é você investir 300 mil
dólares nesse cara aqui os investidores
resolveram investir e resolvi fundar a
empresa é essa empresa hoje ela atende
ela tem como parceiro e teve como
parceiros maiores blogs e sites do
brasil é vários grandes formadores de
opinião independentes que usam a boo-box
e outros meios inclusive suas próprias
áreas comerciais e tal pra gerar
dinheiro é com publicidade se mantém
independente se não precisar serem
absorvidos por grandes grupos de mídia
para continuar formando opinião é mais
do que isso através desse site box
alcança 67 milhões de pessoas no brasil
67 milhões de pessoas é maior do que a
população da frança são seis em cada dez
brasileiros conectados uma empresa que
hoje tem 40 pessoas que começou aqui em
brasília em uma quitinete ele na 211
norte
além das duas das pessoas que a gente
alcance obviamente a gente tem que
apresentar publicidade essa peça
publicidade é dos maiores anunciantes do
brasil
é muito legal você vê que os anunciantes
estão acreditando nessa proposta então é
ea gente está conseguindo atender gente
de tanto renome e de tanta reputação e
quem faz isso não sou eu é um equipe na
verdade então é não é o marco gomes
marcou mas é só um
um porta-voz aqui na verdade é a equipe
de 40 pessoas que trabalha e trabalha
muito e esse trabalho desses caras é tão
bem feito que a gente conseguiu ganhar
vários prémios ao longo da nossa
história é por exemplo uma das 50
empresas mais inovadoras do mundo
segundo a fast company
a segunda empresa mais inovadora do
brasil e do mundo não há segundo uma das
50 empresas mais inovadoras do mundo
segundo fast company
a segunda empresa mais inovadora do
brasil segundo a forbes capa de época
negócios capa da próxima etapa da pgm
entre tantas outras aí está o
reconhecimento dessa equipe ea gente
volta pra esses caras dentre esses oito
caras aí tem dois que são um pouco mais
importante pra minha história guardou
mundo robert nós quem for da área de
exatas aqui provavelmente da engenharia
vai conhecer pelo menos gordo muro da
lei que muda a computação esses dois
caras é de alguma forma uma sequência
imprevisível que as estatísticas jamais
conseguiriam prevê você conhece
imprevisível de acontecimentos me ligou
há uma faixa 18 esses dois caras que
mudaram a história da humanidade que
mudaram o jeito que a gente lida com
tecnologia de dois caras são fundadores
da intel que é uma das investidoras da
boo-box estão de alguma forma o trabalho
que a gente fez um trabalho que a gente
faz gerou valor suficiente pra quê
além daquelas 90 e tantas empresas que a
gente olhe lá no início porque tem uma
empresa no brasil com 40 pessoas super é
de alta performance mas super pequena
que olha só está sendo impactada lá
pela forte audi semiconductors além
disso uma das consequência previsível de
de fatores também levou por exemplo o
menino do gama lá a e palestrar sobre
economia criativa e empreendedorismo e
liberdade de expressão na internet na
onu em nova york
então a lição aqui eu já estou bastante
meu tempo a lição aqui que eu queria
deixar para vocês é o seguinte você usa
táticas como retrovisor ou que alguém
que faz estatística mesmo temos alguém
temos alguém alguém que fez estatística
no curso de engenharia alguma coisa
assim tá bom essas pessoas provavelmente
vão querer linchar quando sair daqui mas
o lance a estatística não é que ela é
ruim e que ela não deve ser usada longe
disso mas eu como empreendedor gosto de
olhar as estatísticas como retrovisor e
não como um trilho eu gosto de ver o que
aconteceu com elas e não que elas me
deixam me permitem fazer então não fico
olhando o que eu vou fazer porque as
estatísticas dizem isso ou aquilo eu
olho o que aconteceu portanto a taxa de
sucesso dos meus negócios com a taxa de
conversão das minhas propostas
comerciais etc
então vamos às táticas como retrovisor
não contribuo elas não devem limitar o
que a gente pode fazer
e aí com as ferramentas que me
entregaram tudo que podia fazer nada mas
a força de vontade transformou o veneno
em combustível para um sonho
já cientes de que há de esperar o
tamanho dessas hora mas ele está apenas
bala agora os ricos a bola porque eu não
fiquei calado disse encorajado
fui ameaçado não desvincula da cidade
não me deram apoio para checar os
obrigado porque não foram ouvidas de
movimento